[Music]
oh
I
[Music]
[Music  ]
to
[Music]
[Music  ]
hi friends how are you
all friends it makes me so happy to see
you again for this first
show of the roland garros i series by
pnb paribas the habitats I am  so
happy it's been a while since I
've seen I'm super happy
a really crazy and rich show
today we're going to talk about ea sports from
two games in we're going to talk about sports we're
going to talk about the history of roland  garros
and all that accompanied by juice alone from
the only reeves and friends and it's going to
be so cool it's going to happen to them
how who's going to win it's going to  u are fine well
yeah you know when
i hear roland garros story 10 sport sport
rives du lac was prepared a few
things i prepared a few things to be
imaginary which i am very happy to
find for this show the
last time that  we the last time
when it was when it was seen that we
have information that we had spoken I had
let go of you 25 are therefore commentators
that his mother had cost a little
expensive I hope that  won't cost me
as much this time having, as you
said frankly, a great show
since here we are going to talk about it
's roland garros cseries of the
qualified also talked about what happens
next because this show will
not be the only one
we will also have  guests end of course I'll
let you do the topo a little bit but
in any case big show over the two
hours which is coming exactly in fact
we talked a little bit about the program
friends we'll tell you so of course he's going to
see the rolands  guy  ros cseries bnp
paribas the final of the general public tournament
we will be able to speak with the two
finalists and moreover speak to them
before and after the match
he will have an exclusive interview friends
with yannick agnel it will
be incredible
for those who do not know  not former
french olympic swimmer jacques
gamblin picouet quite exactly
watch out i'm waiting leave me i want to
be dark skinned i was going to put dark skin on him
and that's ok he directs
it he said he said and of course  now
also for some that maybe the
new generation knows him maybe
more about sports director of the mcs team
I have a little quiz coming to the
bank we know the bank you do
n't know thighs so baron will have to
test anyway  the little rives
behind we have a little interview which is
going to be super nice with the young
talents of bnp paribas
here it is going to be cool with the young
talents so we are going to talk with two
young people who are  didn't necessarily have to
have tennis balls but also that they
love gaming so we'll be able to
ask them a lot of questions
the names of course gabriel de bruz and
aluan changing rooms so that's going to be cool
and we're going to see our little one  chronicle
of the history of roland garros with their
image I was obliged I was obliged I was
told you want to come by roland charest
wait I'll see if there isn't
anything to say about rolland and six on
balls about French tennis  there are
bound to be lots of things to tell
so I prepared little things with
a little quiz also for you you
won't be outdone so on a
human head test but I also tested that
it worries me I like it and well  of
course friends during this live a
lot of things to win what I'm
starting to tell you not of course of
course tickets for roland garros
we'll tell you to feed volley
and besides it's going to depend yves watch
he's under pressure that  will depend on ri  re
in the back the first quiz games we
will immediately he will have eleven
questions if they arrive answers this
question
bnp paribas offers two places for
roland garros of this year I specify
well of this year because surya
plots like bernard  but when
is it going to be done of course from
this year so two places and I
think it's a bit of the same story for me if
I answer completely there will be four
places to win a little bit sure to  from
roland garros if all goes well
if all goes well there are four
tickets up for grabs for roland and that's
going to be cool it's going very nice after that
i'm not hiding from you friends in
the headset i'm trying to negotiate with
the French tennis federation in
particular aymeric so that they buy
the most places you know you
know your range rog assures we
will see that on the show if it goes
well it will crack exactly
and of course keys for the game temis
my  return 2 am  is we're going to make you
win keys to this game also
during the show
and above all, don't forget that there's a
pretty cool thing throughout
the show,
it's that we created a hashtag rives monf
d  elsewhere I think he will appear
as he said he had the idea
these rhythms years ago I was ok ok ok rivenet
me I love you can come on
twitter commented with ribemont and here
we are going to choose two or three  people
to come and talk with us at the end of the
live
it's a concept that I like to come and
talk with fans so friends
do not hesitate to interact during the
live with the hashtag rives monf you
will have someone from our  team who will
come to contact you to come back to
interact at the end of the live with
us asked questions room and
finally do what you were talking about
that's obviously going to ask
questions that's super cool and also on
the on  the format because it's true
that we have a big show is in fact
what is co  ol it's that in the
background and as a red thread precisely of
the show that we are going to do together
mouth with the many guests that we are
going to welcome
we are going to have the final of the qualifier so
wearetennis of these roland garros is here
is  because in fact the roland garros
series is a big competition
online and offline and of course the game
as you said tennis world tour there are
eight qualified in all and it was
everywhere around the world there was in
france in brazil  in germany in
belgium in the united kingdom in spain in
italy and there we are on the grand final
so from the last qualified wearetennis
and basically each winner of the qualifiers of the
qualifications goes to roland garros to
participate and indeed in the final
draw that we will draw lots  at the very end of
the show together gehl so it's a
big show there is still 5000
euros in cash prize won and on top
of that a week two ends of
when precisely with our friends from
emc is that  they support  it's roland
garros is here is so here is the
program is going to be very nice
is so there we are going to have and well the
last qualified for this tree for this
final tree that we will see that we will
discover later at  complete which will
give us a little bit we're going to say
balls for this table which will be at the end of
May exactly that's too good we're
cool it's going to be cool I think that
right away we can already we can already
right away I  think we're going to see behind
the two finals and I think
we have the air of a final in fact has the two
finalists so this
check thank you and dull uses so
they are
so they are the two finalists  so
I did not specify but in fact how
were we qualified each of
each of the members as acquired
participated in fact it is members
of esports schools all
over the world and basically cds and  so
and so suddenly here they are ready
for an interview like that o  We're going to see
a little about the idea of interviewing see how t
ey feel a littl
bit just before this final we're going to see a
ove all with the little pressure what
he pressure is by saying hello to the gas hello
hello  benevolent words
you are expected from the crowd to a little
stressed but that's okay that's normal
his task sees that and everything so you have
guys how long have you been
playing this game anyway the first
stupid question doesn't  not lacking for
its part of science and science and
in september
I've been playing quite regularly since the
release
ok ok we both had great
great the game so so so it's cool
is what is in tennis or
in return I ask myself the question
are there some players stronger
than others really escalating from the two
meetings cm it's the pressure that was
on the right track
[Laughs]
I don't take it as a victim
is my choice
djokovic in real life there are a
few players who  are a little
above and also there are still
very good level all the same yeah you
play with me I take isner to the
family it is not said that you
had styles at the level of the zeks incredible
it is the gameplay  stay is a big
serve
it's going to hit hard it's going to hit hard
how have you
already faced is it the
first time you play against
each other or and what is that  gave
we already know how to play a lot of forums
clearly I don't even know but it's
always really very close matches
so there today
it's really going to be the one who's going it's going to
be the one who's going to give  the little
extra touch I think be
careful be careful coming I have a
question for you you from me very quickly
isère where they hold dominique well if
I like dominique team in real life
for the moment I have so therefore you are leaving on
steam
yeah me I go on steam so the object
3.19 what I take my god nor average
me I  n'ai quoi j'aime d'amour unique
team sera dominique teamfoncia
should say it's a small
question also guys this is your
first final of a game where you have
already experienced low others others
other competitions this
is the first time it's me
personally this is the very first
time i'm not a punishment on
the video game so really new ok
me this is the second time last year
j  I had already
qualified for last year's series
which had been canceled for the
general public and it was at
the Essonne league in Sainte Geneviève des Bois
it started with that so I can
already see that you  you have an advantage believe that
rive judges he is good he with he
has experience but afterwards there is the ardor
also you saw in the ardor also the
mouth but in any case it is
interesting because it is a game of
tennis porto  that I had the opportunity to
test
I had not understood everything we will say the
mechanics at this mo  ly there
though i play other
tennis games so i can't wait to see how
did you get on in a year you
mastered the game how did
you manage to control it how well you
get on and good to use  the
specificities of each of your players I
'm very curious to see that guys and
frankly I wish you good
luck for this match which is going to be very
interesting to follow and I remind you
there is a place in the final table
could you be there?  already a place
to go to roland at the end of
May so it's already a great goal
is so me I wish you good
luck to boncourt to recycle that a little
more comfortable but still has a little
more haysbert  game she dominique team
clings to everything so guys is
really good luck and good courage
what thank you thank you very much to the clothes
we will follow quickly I think the
start of the match if we can together
gaël just to see a little bit
the state  of course  me when you see two
players but I'm very interested
because I haven't had the opportunity
to really get my hands on this game yet
but I haven't been able to play outside and
inside besides listening apparently will kill
I pay for it  very good at 1
apparently I had quite a bit of
ability or two I feel like
I have to disappoint the magnitude and I have to
say at the same time saw him saw my start
to the season I understand that I disappoint
what  it works we have a little video
with other interviews of other
players we can we can send your share
of friends it's in the norm
native it's incredible
you speak and on the shore I made the
fries combining game but  I'll tell you about it
I preferred when I
was a child it was mcrae hill
and like cars and how I loved to
play and he had the most jersey to
believe you such as the ghana royal on August 22
it's clear watch out he  have to think
about mecca
we saw it the sign is something to say
that he will not be nadal is  here the
banks bnp paribas too well suddenly
we saw the different participants
you saw that they are qualified in
the eure in their qualification we will
say and in their respective schools
so be italy united kingdom as you
said
brazilian too so  done with his
leftover gustavo kuerten jersey and too
stylish we're going to get the videos and
everything is too clean and so they
'll all be together at roland garros
for the final table it's going to be
a sick experience
honestly an exhibition an experience
crazy by the way choice that we are going to
watch them a little bit the start of match
3 which has just started the start of the
match so we leave domi
we will see very well ok here we go
so suddenly dominique team against isner
oh my there potato monday believable sam is
already a huge patagonian praline it's
too good but isner against tim geithner
six facades of the dull uses so I
remind you he we know the two players in
fact compete for all  look for
a place in front of the different
participants that you saw earlier
so here I am not yet at
roland so they still have everything to do
in this in this meeting
timing what we could also have
asked them when why why these
nickname what is it true chuck norris he
plays with them john isner you see that there
is bound to be something when there
is something bound to be safe on the timings
when I tested judge I didn't have it at
all it was unbearable
and there he  does perfectly well each
time and we are sure that there are
many variations of effects from
dominic thiem from fifteen days they
did not have the lober olalalala come up
to the net the absolute and suddenly there is
already 1 game to 0 for isner
30-0 now complicated am I
at bata capri sun for me it's
sad to parade kapissa you know
that I'm not too clean and you it's
which one you  prefer to play isner or
team team I can't win  r
tim i can't win i find that
frankly he
the asf beat anyway it's a
monster them
i want to say top 3 top 3 why
i say top 3 we'll tell us why
not above but  inevitably rafa number
one and with novak and him you really see
it's the top 3 is very very hard to
play very very hard guy and young atypical game
your big a big server
big server big hitter so it's
it's always  crazy hokuto matches
it passes one day his caste the
next day it's quite complicated but
what's more what you need
tennis is what it is I
know that for example it's like that  in
chess you know when you lose against a
guy it's that you're marked a bit
psycho-rigid lie in fitness mode
gym got all of it what it's
like in tennis you see like I
'm like you want to find one right away
tactical solution you see if not from
time to time they don't beat you what
is stronger than you but you  you want
to find a little tactical solution
and it's often you that it's often
where you say that you start on the dark side
in things that are a bit dark
because after all their cheeks of
course change  small things so
finally on it you go you often we still
try to evacuate fairly
quickly we will say it's defeat
what to travel to June 20
well listen in any case for
the moment it's quite tight in the
second game  there are fairly long exchanges
you can see changes at a
lot of angles I find in the
game there I don't know about you but I have
the impression that when you play cross
and uncross cd cd
yeah launched and above all they show
very fresh or on the pitch like they
're always in question at all the
games they're at the net so that's
enough it's quite special in that way the
stroke of courage by all the friends and we
'll see at the end at the  end of this game to
watch the latest games and of course
also spoke with the two finalists
and there I think it's time and
it's time to welcome yannick agnel
is a believer and I went through yannick
agnel sports director of the mcs team
who is there incredible Olympic medalist
d  'where the Olympic champion how are you
yannick that's it I have an
incredible melon superman is very well and you
how are you yannick witness me I
'm super happy we don't know each other
very well we met we already
talked  but I didn't know is very
well and when I was told about that and in
addition you what you were doing I said it's
incredible I have you I'm not happy
to be able to talk to you this
moment  so super happy I have lots of
questions to cut is that I am
I am the fanboy I am the fanboy I
tell you right away there is so much
correlation natural general this spirit
a little bit of competition I mean that
on the other hand  I was watching the game I'm
told if there's something when you're gone
2 m you have to
see he is however the guys say
we get along
very well plus it's fun to have
you yannick because live
this weekend we were watching you
watching them  relay of the
london relay live and we all had
chills watching it and it brought
back great great memories
so here is yannick located there too with
us today it's because well
you're now sports director  from
the mcs team so who is a club an
esport club so he was a high-
level athlete you have now made this
transition to video games
so it's true that it's this
transition in the end you have the impression
that it's  is a big gap you see
between sport and history but you it
seems quite natural because you
did it quite quickly after your career
finally yeah I do them quickly
and then I always played video games
between between two  competitions between two
training sessions it was a way to re  ster
connected with the friends with the family
so so as soon as the career stopped
we will propose that and then it was a
time when there were not yet
many many sportsmen you see
on the sports field I  I thought it was
great to be able to
but the two passions at the same time is
to try to be useful, especially months of this
is my first question it's you see
necessarily being a sports director there
are still a lot of
responsibilities and in relation to  you
see as a sportsman you know all the
responsibilities we have how you can
express to me how how you find
because I think he gave himself
line anyway as a sports director
because you can talk to me a little  of this
parallel a little so it's much
worse as a sports director
than as an athlete because
when you are an athlete
you work every day and then afterwards
it is you who is in control of your  destiny
on the ground where you see v  really in
the water the lata just shook
while my players were
drunk so it's true that
it's not easy but I think I'm
trying to bring I'm trying to
bring them in any case everything all
the  experience that I have had during
all these years all these are all the
pitfalls that I have been able to confront myself I
try to do their work
was simply so it goes through
treating them like
top athletes  level that is to say the
physical preparation followed by
nutritional psychological medical
everything you can imagine my you
have images of here is horror of a
certain expertise also a series with
the icc say yes to the rsa it is  quite
nice so we try to make it
suitable the goal is not to make them
do you see 50 push-ups and then
we liked it we liked it behind the computer
but really now it is suitable
that it is suitable  thoroughly so that they
can feel in full possession
of their faculties q  that they are that they
are full of energy and then who also
feels progressed and besides
that's what we're going that's what we're going to
offer to the winner of the di
series tournament that's  to say a week a
week in the in the mcs structure and
and that they can precisely benefit from
all these tools there in this exactly what
we see there on the screen and then the
advice also from the coaches and
the management
because it's true that what
surprised you the most when
it happened is to say that it was with swimming
it's a sport where there is a lot of
fatigue it's extremely demanding  you
spend a lot, a lot, a lot of
time, let's say, in the pools, you're also there
when you're athletic, you spend a lot
of time in front of your screen, what have
you been able to compare perhaps in terms of
fatigue in terms of the jura among the
athletes I believe that the difference
is that fatigue in
athletes is less visible in quotation marks
even for had  x a family that is
nervous and where we sometimes tend
to hide it because precisely as
it's not it's not physical we can we
can be tempted to train for several
hours in a row or even too much and
in the end  to blow a hose
unfortunately quickly
you see in your career the goal for
us is to achieve that having
it is a little bit cut at All Saints' Day
not new but being at your maximum
that's what you said in  the goal
is to motivate them without tiring them
too much either so that they arrive
we will say when we are going to say at the
top what that is and then as
long as possible especially the goal it  is
that they don't stop their careers at
22 23 being completely disgusted with
the world of ispor but that they
can you see for a moment a little bit
of what is done in maths in sion
now last until or  in tennis is
up to thirty years old more than 30 years old
largely because we become
professional because we  gives itself
the means whereas there are two frescoes
still 20 years 25 years it was unthinkable
the paroxysm of your career it was at
24.25 and behind you was a
description what therefore
therefore the goal where the cdc of these of
to professionalize the practice is
to try to give the players as many
chances as possible to
live from their passion I
have a small question also in
relation to your retraining you are going as
an athlete you see when you made
this transition is  what
was it that you were afraid of were you afraid
a little bit of missing out it was to dominate
what you were afraid of embarking on
an adventure in the end as you said at the
start it wasn't  so well known you have
the ea sports you comment to manage this
parameter against when I stopped my
career directly after for me
it was the senate you talk about adrenaline
because it was really the key word
I had myself  said it is absolutely necessary that I
find an occupation
something  daily that they make you
feel the same adrenaline the problem
is that as a general rule appear
thomas pesquet there you see in the ss
emmanuel macron who manages the pandemic
it's a bit complicated to have the same
level of adrenaline as  a ticket to the
olympic games so so so behind it
i fell back on things which
surprisingly provide energy and
a desire on a daily basis which is which is
quite nice it can it can be
in entrepreneurship it can be in
something  quite cross-cutting
like a sport comedy for
example in very different fields
and what is important for
me is to manage now to
give back a little bit everything
that was passed on to me at the time during  my
in my career and I have the opportunity
to do it you see in esport I have
the opportunity to do it also in swimming
now a little bit and I try
to help future generations it's
so cool  that you're talking about that because I
'm  was listening to insee at a gallop I came
across the interview you a long interview
he had given in a podcast and where
you were talking about yourself about your
career as an athlete and that even you
had you had not been a cantor of the
nutrition also at one point and that
I understood there was a
world record that had been made after a
not very popular week don't have
to say that but that's also a little bit
what I mean all this
leaden screed sometimes you put on the
athlete sometimes not there you can you can
be as many times behind him it's
a world and it's just him who takes
his responsibilities so you have to succeed
in accompanying him I think
smart enough what I think the goal
me what I call it the
tool box in fact you give him the tool box
inside not all the means to
perform and behind the goal of
the device the goal of the head the goal of the
player  pro it will be to know each other as much as
possible to know  know exactly what
he returns to know what he
needs on a daily basis
if he needs to have a preparation
that is greater at the physical level
than the others if he needs to go a
little more to the gym he  go a little more to
the room if he needs to go see
the shrink a little more because he feels
he needs to have someone who has
a look a little more
in  height compared to what he does
on a daily basis and well he goes a
little more but in any case we have
to manage to offer all this arsenal
there so that he can be wherever
he actually is  performing behind
yes it's true that after swimming
which isn't as professional it's not
as little as it
can be I imagine tennis football
professional sports
literally afterwards it's true that  this
story of mcdo is so much we
start saying that we refuse everything with
me because in fact what is happening
and that you are doing  s your world record over
200 m in a French championship if
I'm not mistaken
and in the week preceding the competition
you eat McDonald's three times that's it no
it was three days before three days
always more exactly it  is
exactly that you see when they eat
these little nuggets the one in front of
everyone before the final we have an intox side
and utah a side when epr were ready
you see then obviously you don't have to
do it over an entire year because
it's  just not tenable for your body
you see quite simply but there
I was ready but that's it but
speaking of a rate that I have a question
that I really want to ask you
two as I hold you
top-level sportsman it's you spoke yannick
in this same interview of the
call rooms in fact it's the call room
that are helped place you talked about
intox or really about sega we look at each other
we go from there  we put pressure
on ourselves we finally gauge each other and sometimes you
say that  in these call rooms
which are in swimming just
before entering the pool there
are things that happen a little bit
does that exist also in
tennis you are in when you know you are going
go on the court as soon as you are white-hot
on a grand slam final table
do you move a little bit
with your opponent it can be seen
every sport I was of course thinking about
tennis there are different there are different
types of personality but in  to one who
immediately you want to tell yourself
it's rafa you won't get when he the
way they warm up their knees
before entering the hallway she and she
is different you see it means that  at the
beginning
necessarily some people because
he is still quite aggressive
pedess he does sprints he
pays his routine finally is required to
see
you will see that of djoko he is
really able scene where you see he will be
in the breath  he will do you see
he v  to put yourself in positions a
little you see yoga or
whatever will do and you will see nick who will
be listening to are
grooving maybe tattoo what you see
you see the others  people they are
a coach century they do little
immigrant looks but yannick like 8th
say all the preparations of
anyone of any name you
know that at some point it all ends up
in the same place before the competition and
that  people they don't know a tube
she always has a moment
all end up in the same place it's our support
for her downfall the best stud the
biggest possible to be sure to be
the biggest guy in the
bedroom  call because you still find
yourself at eight iep you see that they are we
will say between 1.90 and 2 m so if you
make to put 5 2 meters 6 7 you see
your not bad a little Assange gossip has
all started  on tiptoe
as a symbol of their risk because
it is a memory formed  e call like that
a moment of really very strong pressure
where you feel that you may have
won a race but maybe
tipped the destiny of the competition a little
bit so the dungeons watson at my house
it's  something crazy
everything is ok but soon don't do your
father me personally no it's not two I
have no memories where I would say to you
like me with my attitude I had
the thing changed however the game
look at it  4 x 100 m in 2012
the call room of this 400 meters there
she was at was daunting
because everyone had their role and
precisely because we did not enter the
game of others to lose energy  to
be brainwashing
you see we know we kept
repeating ourselves we have ten repeat title 50 times
listen we have nothing to lose we know
that fun we give it our all and then
come what may what then  that the
others arrested matt get angry if you
want through the media since I
don't know anyway me and we didn't
lose  energy in there and we
weren't going like an Olympic final
just tried I think that
's what made us win in the
end yeah that's crazy and besides
because precisely you are the  last
torchbearer sure sure sure sure this 4 x 100 m
it's you who make an
incredible comeback painting 20 years we watched
we saw live and precisely the people
in the choice of their ask the question
because we know we s  a
technical question was asked also I can be a
parenthesis swimming in it is roland
garros it series by bnp paribas what
is the point of the relay between what
importance of order the souls and sorry
it is only important in
the  athletics is really important
in the relay you see and in
attack what is the importance in the role is
to be oneself a third or
fourth abc is capital it is
capital
so already in fact its a kind of game
of  failure because you have to know
you have to guess who next to you is going to
be in the  line that is to say
first in 2nd 3rd 4th position so
if you have michael phelps next to you too
you have the weakest guy on the
united states team it's not the same already and
after that it will be to calculate  depending
on the times more or less who will be good
and in general the title which is fourth
so the tickets really the last
torchbearer is the magic cartridge he
is the guy who walks on water
during this season in 2012 at  game
it was less in 2013 it was for
example jérémy stravius you see either exact
y the same relay in barcelona at th
world championships not r
ally his tour every year and there
for once it was great since
in addition in third posit
on he  so there was clement lefert my friend
clement lefert with whom I
trained if you want all my youth and
in nice whom I know well only a
very very close friend and we played a
lot on this synergy there too
to know that he was  3rd who
would give me the r  I thought no matter
what happened you see we get high
ray for each other
so it was it was pretty cool too
cool take a good memory I guess
but [ __ ] so your best memory
we'll say in your career you  which one do you want
it's a fact located in will choose
it's a good question
it's a good question I would say the
thing with the relays is that it's not
necessarily intuitive knowing that we are an
individual sport at the  base but the
relays when you live with yourself from the inside
you have time to live it three times
more finally since in fact you
watch your friends swim there is a
crazy atmosphere
everyone is super chauvinistic so you
don't get along  talking you see on the edge
of the basin
I would say that the 4 x 100 in london it
was it was pretty crazy since we did
n't expect it either that it was
before the first day of the competition
and then afterwards  200m was a
race it's talent
I'm sure you lived there  are
matches like that gaël but it's
stuff where you really don't touch the ground
what where you get out of there you say but
it was so easy what everything
goes in everything goes in it was
crazy I  I have a memory of telling me you
see on these 200 m to the 150 m I have a
memory
of thinking well well go now I
accelerate because it's a little easy
and that never happens
finally arrives ready to go  instant t what
was it really it's crazy what you
realize you are what you had you had this
feeling you too won in castres
on a match you know it was
important is in web mode at this little
supplement  I feel that today I
'm fine you see it's happened to me
sometimes sometimes this comedy in
fact unique 7 still happens when you
when you dominate a little bit the thing
in fact it's when you actually allow yourself
to  watch the sport the score in fact
in tennis because often so
everything says to stay very focused I was
playing  really point by point and for
sure when you feel like
maybe you got a 7.0 set you got the break
i'm like wow maybe that's where i
'm going to roll it out what killing the dude is and
like that  rarely happens that it's that
rarely happens in a big match me
it's my happen you see maybe three
four times roland-garros on once
on on matches a little I
thought everything was a little more in
difficulty bank  unroll them i
wouldn't say no because after you
know you're going to replay it the guy is in the
chat and the hell finally the guys have me is
in down mode they said they
were going to unroll this do j  I had but
here you go thank you very much yannick are
these rules so much film will soon
tackle cg one last question you
it's true that you were able to test
different training methods which
is trained in France for a long time in nice
then after you are  also left for the
United States what do you have to take away from
this experience
we will say amé  Rican perhaps your
evolution
in the coaching that you had because
you were really under incubator we will
say in France much more free
certainly in the United States because
it is not the same system
what do you think about it  have withdrawn I think
they are there they are relaxed
in relation to us he
gives a lot he gives pride of place
to accountability, that is to say that
where we were if you want to drive everything
all day and
during training did not know the
line according to exactly what we were going to do
at the beginning of training in the
United States to throw a file with here is the
whole training good luck
trying what you want already there it wants
say that you need a certain amount
of seriousness and responsibility and
then I think that where they make a
huge difference
in our sport anyway is at the level of the
professionalization of the practice
itself
and then  to know how to delegate  iff in
france you know we have this thing of
sometimes having the coach guru
the coach who does everything so you see
that he wants to have the control of a
fifty-year-old this image there a little
yeah and again philippe philippe he  has
an image but but he is hyper pro and
he tries a title that is hyper human
you see in the milk brim in
the affect timmins I think what
makes the difference in us is that you
have a side a little  a little more against a
little more business and suddenly they
will do everything
so you will see the coach the assistant
coach the assistant coach's water carrier
the physiotherapist the thing everyone
is at the edge of the pool
and everyone takes care of your
performance and that in fact allows you not
to have I believe too much a certain
screed a little lead you have on the
shoulders of on the shoulders of
the coach who must take care of being
all at once and that's it's rather
beneficial and that's what we're trying
to apply by the way  I don't know if
I was going to tell you that now you
can use it as a sports director
I have a little question which is
also finally which is not bad and which goes from the
affable French cat you see he says what is
the  best irl sport to prepare
players at mcs i think it's a
good question it's a good question
i think we're still
researching we
're still researching you see on
what's  the most adaptable
what is certain is that you
take because you have to take according
to the already physical level of each player
you can't go and ask the players
to go and do 90 minutes of football
if there are any  have trouble already at the
base you see running or some are used
for cycling
so it already depends on the physical level
of each player
then I think that crossfit is
not bad since it affects almost
everything at the same time you have  a power body thing
that allows you to be
to prevent injuries to be more
alert in front of the computer and
then after you have you are going to have
sports quite specific practices
I am thinking of group practices
for games you see where you need
cooperation where that  will facilitate
the learning of communication
I had thought at one time
fencing too since it was a
question of precision reflex and then
because his hand was also protected so
it was certain that a person was going
getting hurt while having a certain
posture and getting tired quickly
but this crime is really a good
score but it's sure that you arrive early
rugby leaders I know I'm not
sure it's the
best bonus  First of all, it's maybe not the
first sport you're going to do, especially
if, as you say, there are some that have
very different and very disparate levels
physically speaking, but no, but
it's true why fencing is
interesting  golf maybe  re for
concentration also on another area
it can be swimming it's not bad
that it's very complete you preach your part
west now now that it's
the others who dips her breasts go
ahead guys let's go  let's go let's go thanks
thanks to you really too cool what
thank you thank you very much and yannick thank you
for your time and especially see you very soon
win that I hope that in false if we
take we can exchange because with
great pleasure I think that  that we can
save what thank you for any
information thank you with regard to fairy tail
and yannick that you have roma it was you know
that happens I hesitated
to tell him what you told me rov does
what you know  when you asked for
there to be no key on the bmx or brad
on his second part of his career
stops at 24 why these colleges
image of a guy often manages to ask
a question find in front of the fait
accompli ok thank you  much to the monf the
room equal no but it was super
interesting to see  r to chat
with him and it was it was really
very very nice
are we taking the opportunity to do a
little update on the match on the match
exactly because johnny already
has johnny already burned or not what
are we what are we good there
how is that the score of 7 0
for johnny yes yes
appeared how its bad way away from
zero what is it what was beautiful it  was 25
except that we bet in the china team
there were no sums at stake
it was on the other but I'm
leaving I'm moving I'm not going to stay
good in any case that's fine  is a little more
attached there is a team everywhere that
makes 15 euros but honestly he will
do as we will ask them the question
and we will tell you honestly all the same
chuck
yeah because it's chuck like my
guy now I'm  call qadir
sheikh
he seemed calm to me before the final
he still seemed much more
finally less stressed much more
relaxed also I know that  I felt a
little more serene to tell the truth
when you said iem I was a little
happy because I find that you see
I found them hyper stressed you well
yeah in fact the thing is that
news pitches past his first
participation  in competition what
do you see and it changes everything the fact of not
playing the liturgy at your house but he has
already played one already he has already made
competitions by not being at home and it
changes everything for the elbow sneezes it's
his  first competition so obviously
he apprehends it he's there in a
studio he knows that people who
finally watch and suddenly not necessarily
it changes a lot of things bro your
name is land what is it true
following the  north exit which crack
they the moment on this moment there excellent so
we are going to go to the quiz
we are going to come back to the late game and we are going to
go to the politicians yes I know that
all those who know know that I that
I know that you know  that I adore the church
and that above all  ut rives
once again big pressure for you
eleven questions this good answer and
right away it starts to win
places for roland garros friends so
we are fully with reeves we try to prompt
him with the right answers or not
or not finally where  no it's only
tennis questions I imagine suddenly it's
only tennis questions you go to
activities and a little anyway
small questions there are anyway
you should get out of it frankly happens
that I saw them again  the questions how are you
ok but steve said i'm ready
so first question which is very
simple what gestures having marked the
spirits novak djokovic sorry novak
djokovic did he do in 2014 during an
interruption of play due to the rain in
roland  garros basically what did he
do what
he is so a bit a bit atypical
yeah really america is happening I
remember he made a
particular gesture but that's more what it
was what is it  what he does in 2014
dj  oko interruption during the rain 2014
he has to do a little show like
this animation I know you see you
know djoko there he is
he has already worn someone with whom
mine he likes to imitate nadal
he had to throw ipca was frankly very
appreciate  the people they liked they liked
the people they liked finally it was
incredible frankly it was
incredible and I have Messi but he did
not bring a ballboy with
him jeans to protect him from the rain
quite incredible  that you saw the cat
announced that rim on the road that riva
luxe is dead give him we give him the
names no I have in fact basically what
happened is that you said it's a
gesture that was appreciated by the
public suddenly I said to myself what did he
do to appreciate djoko indeed I
remember saying that there is someone
who is holding his umbrella he says to
the person comes and sits next to me
and presto and in fact they are holding the
umbrella of yours umbrella  they run
they fell the images we put
images or images heaps but it's
good you're very very good and at djoko here
you are known to be one of the mud
decide the nicest players are
no longer nice  of the circuit
they have the same thing look here free the
pair a little jog quietly a
treat it's beautiful especially john that you have
me anti small bottle of water there
listen it's a strong drink
while sense of taste  orange or citrus
something like that kills me knowing
in a while it's good sometimes
it's not very good but we give you the
point frankly give you the point there
would be no room there would not be
roland garros' password won for you
the cat I swear I won't have any
seconds we're going to watch a video and
you're going to have to tell me what's going on
what funny gestures marat safin does
n't he celebrate this crazy point in  marathon
yes but one it is not suddenly on
it certainly not roughly it is  how
they celebrate this point what did
i like marat safin as a player who
was not favorable to men
were real serves there is not just a
system and real forehands and
reinforcements and  playing against felix
mantilla there
I also loved some facts
dillmann started what his reaction
how to react marachi not if he was
very expressive I don't remember him
as an expressive player I think he
remains stoic
he remains logical you say yeah  yeah
once twice three times doesn't happen he
remains stoic for me
we put the men and the answer
helping he pays his shorts because you
know if you are it's an image who knows
that even me when he when I read  the
question I immediately have to lower when
he lowers his show in fact it's an
image in tennis jar he's the one
who did what you're going to
lower his shorts anyway
yeah thumbtack ok ok it's  here it is a
big image what in time attention
will arrive ja  but who's taking a
little delay who's taking a little delay
friends so one more video and you're going to
have to tell me if it passes or it breaks
and here it is to be between people but
you have to tell me if that  pass ok if
it breaks very well video of mary pierce
against monica seles at roland
garros what did I love this future yes ok
does it pass or does it
break at its own
rios to me I say  it goes to me I
say it goes it's up to you you go
I believe it I can see it well in fact I
can't see where the ball is but it's
there from the baseline
no in fact it's going to take the ball between
the legs  there she's going to do 28 sly well
me I say that it's ok there's enough
hiking so what do you think she's
going to pass long lines there because
there's a big and a huge hole I
don't know if that's  a long passing
line but I think it passes the
net in any case ok we go we see we
see the perfect response did something
the goal so much  she does a press cross lob
when her pass you say no but
obviously i had seen the space behind
injured that's exactly it of course
wait i knew she sticks and the
net i was going i'm sure you put a
point like that you say but in the end I
'm so I had seen it's sure in
time damn you get out you're not doing
badly what yes
third question so there it's going to be
a multiple choice question
how long did the
2004 santoro clement marathon
match the longest match in the history of the
tournament 5h57 6h33 6h59 or 70 01 oil &
gas don't give up 6h50 hofu 7h01
really do something taboo
anyway tennis players every time I tell myself
that you  still made matches and
had a lot of great
stuff
6h59 or 7h01 6h33 it's not a match
François only 60 hours 5h57 I think
it's not that happened and is happening
it's  passed it has not unfortunately not if it will
not it is grated to know 6:30 359 7:01 6 and
7 hours 5  6 and 6:59 a.m. or 7:01 a.m. you
're really you're really not
nice because it really plays a
minute to our expectations be
careful
ok I have in fact there is still a
barrier bar 5 p.m.
anyway who what is happening  go over what
it means that's what finally every
minute is important of course of course well well
I'm going to say 6:59 am theekoye 659
6:59 am whip listen
the correct answer is there and several 33
6:33 am aulas makes that I'm not going to say the
3g with  6:30 a.m.
look at his federated house they made
marcia points what so I'm doing
this after all that well try to think of
a day after we agree
yeah that's it yes it's trying to
think of nico mahut  and john isner
no it's crazy it's crazy besides that he
had beaten isner mahut I
think that's the longest match that's it
but it was over two days you see ah
yeah it  or c or 6:33 it's not bad but
in fact it's every time when it
serves as a semi-final match they d  have to
play it again in 48 hours
gentlemen hat ride
you give a little but I think well
shores be careful of bad answer to be
careful in dairy but be careful we
had more what to do
small it make or break
with barbara strycova she makes a point
of sick and  you are going to tell me if it passes
or it breaks
it comes I look and besides we
greet her barbara who is the one who announced to us that
she is pregnant not very
long ago she is a Czech player in
my year of age j  I did all my
juniors with her so I'm super
happy for her too good so there
I have to guess if on this one
where ended up limiting splits yeah it
looks vote is their splits allen
incredible flexibility
yes  it's phew so there you have to know if
the ball that left passes or not the
net it passes or it breaks
I have the impression that it went well
no finally I saw to have the
trajectory there j  I have the impression that
it went over the top  of the net
can we put the video back to the beginning
because in fact I wanted to
foreman the point and you are going to take a
good look at the point and it is to see
if it passes or breaks like that you yourself
there  there are no others
it passed passed so she got
the point because be careful it's winning
the point no no no no they don't win
the point that for me the ball passes the
net but the lesson to the notaries so do
n't pass two  nets 11th with there we
know it would pass net and canpages
me I don't have to take stock they
allow through porn it breaks so it
breaks it breaks ok let's go
please video no but wait wait no
more impossible  when i guess there and
she has to put a huge forehand
she finishes the point and it's over
there is no i slip she was
surprised you i think you the terror
advanced calais talent was surprised at
for  me it was ok well well sorry low
that it does not pass it does not pass ugly or in
real you do not gag  don't on the questions
there it's very but very good very good
I like the challenge
you see what I mean she enough
I think it's due without fault to the east
in the chatt icc of the without fault
now  for the finely the places
what do we do with the dishes otherwise
I take them but that's her opus go on
Saturday you know that's it we do
that she had been cursed good
imagine shore they don't arrive  not to
find reveal keep place so be
careful after you manage with my
cat
so it's going to be a
a photo what is the main
novelty of the 2000 to 21 edition of
roland garros it was the nr of course
what was the la  end the novelty
i'm going to try stuff no there's a
photo but that's the answer i'm going to
try td roland garros last year
there was a roof over the track
there but there's something you're only in
france we  l we have always been reproached
you see something in france has
always reproached us that in all the  are
grand slams
they have except them finally we know it's
the roof on the central court and
something else that says you say
something you know I want to tell you
you have fans is what in matches fans
end of the day there is always something
good yes ah yes the night sessions at
is so there towards the east the classes take
place to chew on we want to give you
the yeses but in fact basically I
really thought it was the  roof I was
really staying on the roof yes
absolutely the night sessions with
the lighting and all that absolutely
exactly small photo of the new
philippe chatrier please and
that's really the novelty yes the
roof but  it's above all the roof lighting
so that we can finally for that
scarcity of nike drought and it's
all the same what we play the spots
when you have to serve a kind of
thing usually you get used to it and  they are
well placed normally it's always
you 6 compared to a little bit yours
where you put yourself where you center yourself it's to
go serve or when you go this match
is tempting is not successful and it
's good it's good but
normally no you're doing well what
ok ok very good good I  then learn
this one yes we give it to you we will say
that soon inspires them and
we will give you a video and we will
ask you if it passes or if its class in
fact yeah is that yes
is that what you don't know is that  that you
see in fact I put the ball back in the
field
if it's the only point that it passes
or it breaks it breaks frankly I'm
shot
you win it I believe I'm there no no
you don't win at that you don't win  you do
n't win it you there I don't like you do
n't win you have it you kill the key
but you have it you're so it breaks
so it breaks it breaks for me it breaks
you that you have you don't win it  damn
let i go cross passing brothers
stop video no i think because
i watched i watched accomplices
of you  of your points but that one I
remembered who broke sinai case for
that imagine you put them that one it
is exceptional it is at the service of
the history of roland's points that's for
sure I had made a good opus at  roller
but that they break hard but I
hesitated I hesitated precisely on
another one but it kills me there they broke
so there it's a question and I know
it's going to be you see I have confidence
in you  really and I think that de chat
has confidence in you because it
really shouldn't be that here's to the pact 8 go ahead
younger complex games then
youngest players to have spent
a round at roland garros who
is the youngest player  or
player to have everything so I'm going
to help right away it's a shameful
thing there's no propaganda it's like that
in my head yeah I'll tell you she's a
player and I'm fine it's
they seem to have been world number one
she won at the mythical roland garros
against martina hingis
[ __ ] I po  i can't say no there i
'm not going the way to win her at roland
garros mythical sure martina hingis
nature show too long for me
even in quebec
the rations be careful be careful there it's
still these things cmh and she's
married
with aulas during  she's married to a
player we loved watch out so
who's making his semi-final against
sebastien grosjean at roland garros that's what
you said tadic
watch out it's true he told me listen
what I'm told then  I see but afterwards I
won't be able to find it guys
you're hard it's not going there grosch
delajoux and who he had picked up out of
their roland garros stadium
agassi the addition agassi and she's married
to this guy there she  is married the agaci
she was world number 2 she won
I tell you at the mythical final fim
against martina hingis
I painted the woman damage if I don't have no
dining room I'm sorry I have
n't seen her  i'm sorry i'll
have to take the seats for roland
with i'm going to have to go to roland
garros on my own ouch ouch ouch ouch ouch
it's tartan yes if she had an
exceptional rivalry with monica
seles
no but it's not my generation it's
not bad she's german
she's german I  don't know I
haven't I haven't there I haven't gallant look and
you can shouted you can date arms I
don't have rives game and ederson in you're
going to tell me yes right away
but he's going zy no  2 propose I make
three proposals to you thank you thank you
make me probables at least
probables in celebration should have started
by making pros pale and finally
I would have found that happens it is
probable patty schnyder to which
navratilova steffi graf
it is  small graph I'm really
horrible but it's too hard
oh there it's not my james and phew but
steffi graf steffi graf very good very
good very good but you are necessarily
you know her steffi graf and yes but
name of name  by name of course of course
giving giving giving obviously
obviously mm  is it the fault of the cecc or end of
the war
the youngest is 13 years old it was in
1983 moreover when yannick wins roland
garros at 13 years old and 343 days life
elsewhere worries that she has it's crazy it's crazy
I'm crazy I'm traumatized by a
racket because before there were
metal rackets but really from
the batégails era my brother was doing
squash like that with me an old
racket and he a metal racket
against a wall unfortunately you can see
hitting like that he put me the same
metal racket kind children like that
and I was there but there but claf the
nose with the metal racket
the excellent great match it
was horrible it was horrible we give you  the point
let's arrive total points really
want to replace the bridges the places
so suddenly it's going to be a video and you
're going to have to guess what shot she does
while she broods to do because he at
carolina sorry pliskova is that  she
goes late a dropshot a set of nines a
cross backhand or so  just to put it
in the net what the ball ok that match
where she plays against maria sharapova there
and it's incredible at that moment
now what is she going to do that
in the head of a tennis player
that  are you doing what are you
saying a month great mario players
tell me and there I put a little cushioning
there I put a little cushioning not buddy
forehand that's it the backhand either or
the cushioning c  'is amazing the pictures
please the pictures is lawful the
mortar and that's what I would have done if
I still had tennis think so I
'm not very impressed with the
decision but hey it was yeah it  was
first instance indeed his first
intention i made them i leave very
impressed if the shot is amazing
amazing shot it's exceptional
suddenly next question very very easy
how did gustavo kuerten aka guga
celebrate his victory at the end of the
roland garros final in
2001 on this instant how he  celebrated
I was 6 years old in 2001 game no but it
's shores cd essential
please he had bought my culture well
I'm doing my tennis culture with you gaël
I'm a tennis cutter no I'm going to
think I'm going  think about it it's a
notorious lack that it's him we
don't have at alten m all the cat they
know the cat they are welcomed the
neon lights are hot they are hot you
see I'm not the only one to be
useless for cooking  marion also who says
that it's hard car with the hashtag
rhythm in addition the same bravo maybe
by ion will be among us moreover
maybe marion will be among
us maybe be selected to all those
who react well  sure game while
he thinks shores
don't hesitate to react
it's the name of gustavo kuerten they
die in gaza really great
player and it's amazing gustavo
kuerten what does to celebrate
frankly i allow you  to look at the
cat look at the cat look at he must
make a  ingue
no no we're looking look at the csaj all
received plus cat's look he's making
hearts so what's
he's asking for marriage what's your
answer north but guys what's
your answer he's asking his wife for
marriage for  celebrate what I see
cops everywhere so I guess that's
it I don't know I don't know I don't do
that block in time tada the answer is
he proposes to his wife but
that's what n'  have no other ideas i
saw that so now so gustavo
kuerten
it's hot and like and he's the one
who initiated raymond domenech asked
he wins but wins so it's cool
finally you see jean raymond domenech he
is champion c  it's cool you see no
it's not quite what I wanted
please
please please let's go video we oblige
the ati he said ask his wife to
marry  please the video it's
an exceptional moment he draws a
heart on the exact he draws a heart
is celebrating and after  if he writes in it
tap the rest he writes I want you to
marry me 17
he draws a heart he
lies inside and in fact he had
started doing this you serve his third round where
he had saved match points
against against michael russell you see he
had saved jean croix wasquehal
match point was trailing 2 sets 0 he he
had an incredible comeback and he
did he had drawn a heart and
lay down in it and it was an exceptional image
two  weeks after the guy from roland
garros again and sir he redraws
the heart and not very original because
they redraw the winner while the
standards and the graff grace what the cata 4
seconds so I won the places and
that's the hyundai
there is a damned answer to a
last answer
we will really see in which year
rodger federer he won his one
and only
roland garros in 2009 in 2010 in 2011 or
in 2012
it sings
final rodger federer beats a certain
gaël monfils in half-  fi  nal and down a
certain juan martin del potro and in the
final he beats a certain robin soderling i
hesitate 2011 2012
that's nothing
clan didn't know where it came from and then
it was phew but that's not the answer
n  it's not the answer we're expecting
obviously I see the cat
fussing next to me but I'm not looking at it
don't look at it
baby season you're not going my look at
his days yesterday Chad can't  burn myself
but I would say
2011 the right answer and in 2009
a dog beaten by two years was
not far
[Laughs]
in 2009 it is during the dates I have
trouble situating cif gecko what is happening
so quickly  hugo that's what's going on
gaël that's crazy that we had we had a
question back up because I thought
maybe riva you see a question was going to be
missing you see which I
gave everything where  he in league 2 I'm going to
show you I'm going to ask you a question there
there there you and me like that really skin
for really we'll see if if if you really
want  nt keep the places or not
he's a real rat or not what my
question will be very simple
how many times has rafael nadal not
due to roland garros lost lost that we
lead match did he lose at roland garros
he had to
[  Music]
by losing
[Laughs]
[Music]
it's that olivier mutis the debates you
live seals but it was by roland
garros stay and sex how many times has
he lost at roland garros I hesitate
between 0 and one gentlemen  in fact it
scares me too much that you judge me like that
in the end I am with you great
French tennis player who will mark his
sport and there I am there and I am
not even able to say that it saddens me of
phew Haitians in the house of  eat a
bit we console ourselves a little but
look I'm helping you 0 1 2 or 3 0 1 2 or 3
well you know what
I think he still has 0
or three cars
I allow myself to ckoi Thursday
once once I hesitated between 0 and 1
we're going to ask again the no but
seriously it's in the face of these horrible
c  that's not it he lost twice
officially because once
he actually once he didn't
go to play squarely so that you have he
was injured once is not the
cabbage inc the first  times they
break through and in 2009
officially against robin soderling in the
round of 16 and lost it and
lost it a second time he lost
twice actually
finally i say there without something
two actually
so what ok ok c  is the lack prince
and continues on nova what not rushed
but I'll tell you everything on sure sure
sure novak
let's listen we're going we're going right away
anyway on a last rap question
because we want to give places
when  even it's a question it's a
question we just said be careful
in which year the one and only
french yannick noah did he win roland
garros 85 had killed their image and his
90 years lower but guys is  to
see the cat and months no you can
talk to him like 1.5
no it's  st in 1904
three and we just said it in addition we
just said it was my graphs
going to win in 1983 I tuned
right next to it can't leave me the year
and it's the  year when house yannick i
say them it's there don't come only with
roland garros rings that's what i know
what even if i had to keep the
market places give anyway killed give
anyway because brother i don't deserve
not killing gives anyway so realtv
gives anyway so in fact the bnp
paribas paris not give them to me to the cat
and finally so therefore the bnp paribas
you normally had to give you
places so now benzi series which
gives and places I return the hunts
jorand the places I'm sorry I
'm going there really calmly at 80 and 4 1985
and his 83 and I apologize and if yannick
looks at us most certainly not I
apologize if 1983 téoufa kun it's good
he gave it back  give you back the places
here we go at the end of the match
friends and very quickly  after this quiz
extract bet both from the match they
are in the tie-break in the tie-break
and johnny our national johnny
he is winning to win
in the tie-break 3 1 I leave you a
little commented because I  I'm
still a little annoyed happens anyway that
you excuse me it's true I don't have it I
really thought I had it yet I
shot I tell you with serenity and all
that but at 10:30 a.m. little by little
it  is certainly nonsense but I
apologize in any case like this one at
the end of the end of the meeting between
the two cases there are two heroes there to
for isner and the chalice until the dregs
there will do so  the 25 what
happened to you behind it's hard
ah yeah well listen I know
that I have to progress in time on this not
easier we will see ja come like the
little animation it is that it is true
that  john a you know that every time
tisseyre he passes the ball between
the legs that on two islands we
can reproduce this movement  it's very
hot it's very strong can't you see
he passes the ball between the legs
and I want I want to tell you you
know it's the same thing in
real life
in the  real life you take a look
they get annoyed at perissac not if it's
exactly like that it's clear
5-2 to know how to climb yes
a real potato comes from him there ok a bit short on
the season in the mountains he hasn't  on the other hand
to each are almost frankly but
me what impresses me is a little
is the change in the facts what you are going to
exchange really the effects
between the slice the dish and a lot of
that it is to see boy a lot
of stations of  the island in fact in his
head I have the impression some that
chuck
he will be there and says to himself I'm going to put on
football it's over quartet but no but he
's there he's good it's when they
tell me when  you are led and still
two sets zero and 5 3 in the tie break
on isère in real you see there you know of
26  t not las vegas of your name you are going to
turn around
oh la there this crazy point yes this
sick point what they are going to hold they are going to
hold
oh la la the passing along the line
I want to note the past of the year 2000
mister jobs elektrim i was coming
big passing it delights me
i want to have a feast my
dominique dispute a big construction site
to comment on the in the high schools
today risk of the call well wait for the
life not do that i show you  entry
we are commenting on the big
incredible I remind him so the one who
therefore each black if for the moment who
is rather well with therefore john isner what
it takes to finish a crowd to
finish a crowd for the table  final of
these roland garros is here is back bnp
paribas he will therefore go to the
final draw at roland garros with the seven
other qualifiers who come, we
remind him of the from italy from germany
from england from brazil so to try
his luck and try  to win 5000
euros of cashprize it is  st a week
two ends of camping with our friends from
mc es so here he is still in the race
well played well played to him well played
also to his opponent determined this gift
which will have tried everything but which
unfortunately lack of experience
chalice until  the lie team that loses I do
n't have I don't have black in 83 we're going we're going to
talk to them quite a bit afterwards in addition I think
we're going to give up cooling down a little bit
take a little back and hydrate
and of course hydrate-  you each time
I'm always important and we'll come back
with a little interview friends as
we told you little interview
with young talents from bnp paribas
friends the young dolphin it's called the
young talents team of bnp paribas we
is pleased to welcome them so we are the
experts now
lohan and gabriel is what compares to
buno of course the gas hi it's uh
yes it's going very well it's going thank you very much
legal has become thank you for taking the
time to come  with us precisely for
fight to discuss we are just taking advantage
of these roland garros cseries bye bye pnb
paribas for also talking about you who
benefits and precisely from the youth program
of bnp paribas you are you are 14
15 years old and his 15th and young 15 year olds
both 15  both to matam
and riffs that would make them you do
something very beautiful to them and everything was
like internal message or serious and the
cases the story presented a little
later I know the guys you're all
there already that from the premiere  question I
have you all right now to me I'm
in my luck ok calm I went
to lille ok so it's gabriel deals in
bittou me I live in grenoble grenoble
grenoble georges deniau right away
me when I'm told  grenoble guys
it's in the rankings what's your
rankings in france finally i'm
ranked 0
ok and unitary i'm 500 lists and
juniors within the chu 500 m
lohan suddenly me in france at home 0 but
it's the rankings  there they are
stuck  with the co empty of the blow when his
revenge - 2 and in itf I am 391
junior so the real ones like war
about
it's the beginning but after these are
small simple questions the boys
first for me it is necessarily  your
favorite players you have what made
you play
tennis guys what made you
play tennis and let's say what is
your dream too well me in my
favorite player it's  is alan carr and 16.5 and and
then what made me wiser in tennis and
my brother who plays before he
started tennis and I was 5 6 years old
and suddenly I am better during these
matches where I  play with my parents then
after I decided to play
tennis school in a club the tennis guide and
after and after I continued with the
competition and and after oloron I am
and who what at astana then there c  it's
his mind has the mind of or end
two days ago here website even if he
lost there it's in the final djoko he made
dream  ver lens it was or do 2 to 5 in
his amount no it's incredible what
he does is all in what he does
the start of the season of sick people who does
and above all it happens alas alas
really a game of  football what so
suddenly you are playing a bit like mutated
aggressive like him because he still puts
only he but only
puts numbers anyway and I don't
only put chicks but I try it's a
yes on the right we die there I'm not saying that
shalit is not saying heat here just that I do
n't play two like him ok ok you lohan
so suddenly at least my
favorite player I would say it's good I
would say djoko so it can do  debate
that too but I've always liked jo
like me and afterwards otherwise I like
when a boot and also because I
like what's around doing
everything that has to do with rap all that
so more j  I like his game all that
how how he finally arrived he is
not very tall and all that comes
a little closer to what I do  s me suddenly
I shimmer or bouchut me I am
right-handed good god and after it was a
lot of criticism way and after the
other questions it was
what it was what pushed me to play
tennis
exactly  well, actually, I also play
football when I was little, I play
a bit of 2 and in the end I chose
tennis a bit, I wouldn't say by chance,
but I played both well, and
after that I decided
to continue.  more in tennis
because I played better than football all that
and after I was integrated into the league of the
French hosts after I continued all
that it went well there since beats it's going
well so sticky with a  little objective a
little short term
when the qu'ovide of course will
allow you to replay it's starting to
do I think degrades two tiers
I have a little more in juniors in the
final with the cockpit it's not
so much the  texans what we can
still play we can
still go to tournaments what we
have  authorizations with the federation all
that suddenly in fact low it's going in fact there are
fewer tournaments and the turns they
are more raised because there will be
fewer tournaments all that but otherwise in the
end we continue all that to play as
before so  it's cool
roland junior this year we were if we
're new because if there's another
card at 1 junior and that would be cool we
'll ask for it we'll ask for it live the
[Music]
veil on the programming when it's  is
your favorite player will have to say
gaël monfils to equal him seems that you
also play serious at strong nights I was told
that fort the guys do not have
fifa on the other hand I was told that you have already tackled me
that  like fifa already the gains we're
going to have to really settle that at the club
because there I'm hot to do a
reeves maintenance like that it comes it attacks me
like that happens I see that no but
after me I'm me I'm with the  fc
6/2 me I would like with my club
me I have my team already so I am a
p  eu pritchard has made a lot of people
apart from the nets I think it's being
free and a lot but indeed
gabriel metals suddenly you have time to
play certain titles at the moment
anyway low at the moment I would do
I  don't play too much finally I play a lot
but with the turns and everything got
complicated what then but normally during the
week on me I'm not around 5:30 p.m.
then afterwards I often have my little time
to myself finally to play or to think about something
else  thing that tennis to go out a
little so so way after game still
quite a lot of time in the evening to entertain
but suddenly do you follow
streamers do you follow youtube
hours on high but you have more joy there
vanilla I had put these names with my
choices ok ok ok I come I
have moreover in the ear rive they say
that lohan look a bit like
obstacles in the chat is
what can we confirm  or not yes it's
breaking because we all agree
bi  in I tomtom because of the very very
good like and suddenly will hear the guys
bring you back a little the wounds the computers
or or not at all I tear myself up and me
he puts us becomes the coach says here
we take a sequence paris marseille
[  Laughs]
yahia phone to catch not far
from 10 in question how that no but
it's because my side I also play
fifa a lot suddenly if sometimes we
are in a tournament in sion before for
example we play in coop
I know that you mouth you only played
bruce grannec and I look at you and
it's too funny to play in coop it's
fifa sweat in division i aiming for one and
where is it
with my coach and well we often play that
but there  we didn't play too much anymore
since we played especially when there
was skin there aren't too many tournaments anymore
and suddenly that's if he likes to play
fifa but if I take him to the tournament and
it doesn't really rock him  I think it's
good in the chat that I see and aya que
gueye who does that in the  s friends I'm
not hiding that we're I think on the
pro circuit honestly out of a hundred players
we're I think 70 know our
playstation minimum friends
yeah wait I'll take it six
months and you're younger must
not not put in the  meats do
n't incite you and whip again and
behind we could take the
playstation quietly but I do
n't have the right I remember at the time
damn we didn't have we were confiscated
and besides you don't do that no
confiscating our phones and the jorat computer
at 9:30 p.m.
it makes you dream a little more in the room it
smells good what they are good that's
clear and suddenly I wonder at your
tasks where you play how many hours of
tennis you train  how many
times a week when they're
not in a tournament
if I'll let you I would say
about a normal week with
more physical tennis on about a
little over 3 p.m. I think like around 3 p.m. I do
n't have  it depends  it
depends on the players there are some who play
more or less but that's fine I don't think well
me I train four hours 4h
soaking in cambrai 20 hours a
week about 10 6 x 20 hours a
week of tennis music combined and
then and then sometimes i
also train and saturday morning it depends if if at
the end of the week i am package
pakao nice normally i also go
training on saturday morning
is what you are framed in the
mental part because i know  that
it is often a question is
what young people they are framed by what
you see a mental coach right
now
me I sent a wind I send there is
a wind when I really needed it
because I  I liked my period a bit when
I got a bit nervous a bit of
deconcentration on the court but
now not too much I
haven't had a mental coach for a year
and a half two years I think because for
the moment  I don't feel I'm not
necessarily the nece  ssary I'm good
in my head
then I'm on the ground I'm having
fun so for the moment I do
n't feel the need
lohan is for me in fact I don't have a
mental trainer or what I've already
had too  before like gad
but in fact I see this game with I
mostly actually prepare a bit
with my tennis coach finally in fact
for example in all training
and everything low for example for example
show at their record in training
don't  can't say that we don't reveal
your secrets
no but if so but here you go you
can you do things
you don't need good days with
here he is every day with my coach in
tournaments all that in the end all the time
when we talk about the matches all to
debrief all that before the matches all
that and must in the end I do I do
mental preparation with him and that's all
exactly
no it's cool here I am targeted sagal
August at 50 with 14 15 years old  young I was an
assistant in the French pole  Finally, I was
a little like France so sent back to you
from time to time there was everything
for sportsmen
since we were in a boarding school so we
saw a person you see once a
month
you see a person but it
I think it was more a bit general than
specific about tennis at the
hockey time and so guys you have
before leaving you alone a little bit
your predictions
this year for roland garros we're
going to do something a little broad
your three favorite of roland garros of
course we all know that there is one which
is vandalism so your two favorites without
rafael nadal what asylum or
me I will just say necessarily game but
djoko km2 in what each time in
large  slam
here it's often it's often
it's seed and after steam I don't really
know because there he has he has a little we
can be in trouble there since the us open
since he won there  so there is
no titillation which is my wish at the
moment but I don't know if in general  and
slam it goes I would still say
citypass since the ace and a half at the
enemy diners the adar crazy match
weitz the golden wave including way in
five months I think
I had still happened in it after
winning  and i think it's still
rafa who will win but i think that
titi not if he can do i can
blow up the thing m
so you will pass nadal djoko stopper and
pass and you see me i can't even
put because and  it's too complicated in May
but in reality the chocolate building at 251
it's not the same I'm thinking of saint
quentin
why did he do it more it was at
home this effect considered reach of gabriel
it's more is this  that he will still have one
more set because accept either that's where
they played three hours 25
is what you see he still had one
more hour to bury djoko yes
but otherwise I really think as he
said if you  passes and then in fact I see
well also roublev months or in short there in
monte-carlo against nadal he made a
big  s big match
then if they manage to s he manages
to get it out it has great
players in the quarter semis it can go
a little missed 10 against great
players roublev there is still
so much alcohol left
it  is beautiful no but not roublev so
roublev nadal and city pass and europe
yeah you pass and also you as a favorite
he wanted the day before watch out guys
thank you very much love them guys
honestly good luck what are your
next budapest tournaments in 4 4 the
same  hoping for a small final of
you two is against each other made
sure get ready not address
friends because when I meet you
it's sure that it will find a
playstation in the corner to my strength have
also prepared  -you fortnight because
I saw when you play with it did a
live with joe isn't too much it had
burst and he stood burst but
ugly ugly no but this is a level
above the saint  ursule if he will
help me no don't worry i will  i
'm ready i'll be ready with ugly
in any case guys thank you very much
thank you thank you for your time good luck
good preparation and i hope to see you
very soon at roland garros if not
this year with a wild card or or
l  year would do there because
because because you are going to qualify
quietly what the qualifications for
roland-garros at least what junior
for me ok me thank the goal
thank you very much and well listen we
read all that very interesting it  is small
it's a small game and that's where
I wanted to see also you know
this new generation like wind
how he the voice and I liked you
see who puts titi not his citizens
it  it's funny all the same when he says to me
roublev the great players roublev he
's 7th in the world I mean that's what
's crazy it's that we're looking and you
they know they're interested makes
a choice he looks a lot when  it's
cool but you know this domination a
little rafah novak e  t and rogers a little
bit you see she is always present
and even if you see in myself I find that
many people do not
realize that marseille has not already tickled
what is good there medvedev which is
good rue blaise which is good  there finally we are
talking about guys who have been top ten since
t34 is sure who has who pays has a
lot more at the door and it's funny
that you see in the minds of
some people still you know it's
abc low  these great players at the table
but who knows how to lead a great player we
will we will also announce the yes the
competition thank you rives to seal place
that exactly it is exactly to
win places later so the
chat please  please friends all you
can say thank you shores
I don't know if we say thank you or not
sitting here thank you to the houses the chat
from now on friends the nay
boots the bnp paribas offers two places
at roland garros so anything you
notice thank you  shores from
now  enant go and draw lots to
win two places at roland garros the
friends of fenaille boot here we go thank you
rives
I'll tell you when it's going to be
closed all that so here you go thank you laughs
I like it I see that I thank rives
mercier wants
all this time we are going to find
the winner of the final so
of the khalife year we are tennis however
that when you are
participating so with chuck 9.6 who
won his victory
against terminals salute each  congratulations
for this match that you still had we
can say dominated it with
isner thank you very much yes so he still
had a little problem with his controller for a
while but in the end very
happy very satisfied with the result
is what I  would qualify we call this
exact body of the first two sets it
was 4 2 3 0 and 4 years is what for you
it's a match it was a
difficult match a match where you immediately felt
a little you  see here a little bit
above all it's matches where you do
n't win with a bit of ease
how did you feel on my serve
I was comfortable almost the whole
match
after I still had trouble
making  but I started the match well all the same
so it
gave me confidence and it allowed me to in
quotes unrolled a little bit we saw
that you play with a lot of angles 20
you I had a lot of  balls crossed
with a lot of envy to say all the same
not badly at the net it's a bit salacious and
its game is it's a bit of the soul and
it makes it possible to protect precisely
to advance more  easily to the wires here
if you if you put low and angles you
quickly take a passing on the other
side all kinds there is no time to
return to the middle of the field
so in fact also go up quickly quickly
what it is  that is to say that you were really hungry
you took the
midfield a lot a lot with isner what after the
earthquake and in izmir but in real life that's
it  his body in the service
he tries to go up on the fly of who
can it's a bit the same gameplay on
the console it's difficult in any case
in the game it's difficult to put a
winning point with whom this nerf from the bottom
short the solution is the volley
efficient service
it is in any case it was very effective
because thanks to this sudden match you
qualify for the final tournament so a
role at the end of the end of May you will
face  so
and a german belgian brazilian
spanish player during another
french player also by the way
augustin baudinet have you
ever faced him do you know him
well well in fact i can maybe their
nickname but like that  ok very good very
good very good but my listening that it
will be a taboo the opportunity to play
with other international players
in tournaments and kind of things
in tournaments have never yet
so stop French players very well
listen to my  first shot good
luck it  it's so cool what it's going to be
super great experience it's the first
time for me so it's fine and well listen
we'll see Thursday towards the east since I
'll also be there normally so so it
will be very this listening good
preparation for  here there and we'll meet at
roland in a month chuck is good
preparation and during this time to be
able
to suddenly the draw is what in the region is
doing the draw now for the places
where are we waiting at the end of the show
with  the other things i think the
draw is going to be done now they have
now it's the wine we're going to
announce the winner
after i feel like at the end in
which so there you can stop
swooning thanks rives because  that the last
winner will be at the end we tell you nothing
will give you the winner with tommy
lane who say yeah but there you can
stop you can stop mylan and
winner we will give it at the end
exactly 7 from two shores
now it's  appetizing in the
chronicle  it's in my little column
I'm going to have to speed up a little bit
because they're at 7:44 p.m. so
so I'd say it's a little bit
but it's gone so indeed
I was prepared a little
story column because I  am a little
bit necessarily interested in discussing
to prepare this program is therefore
I was necessarily interested in a
character who is very well known
today
ap bale who is suzanne lenglen and already
I am going to ask you the question first
what because  the other time we made
a top 10 of sportsmen and women
combined of all time
would you put suzanne lenglen in this top
you can maintain it in this top 10
because she has so I don't I don't
don't know what you have to say in the
column but the lava for
women's sport in any case in her generation
she had a huge impact
so I'll leave that to you so of course
for me I think she's in the
top  10 really in the top 10 of
sports
what I say and is interesting because in
the end I obviously knew
suzanne lenglen from no but it's true
that I I I didn't know her
career at all m already won titles which
are super important she is six times
world champion  six times champion
of France she wins 6 times Wimbledon
three gold medals at the Olympics and 271
consecutive career victories so
it's still it's already
huge from there but I find that what
interested me the most  at suzanne
organs it's her career you saw
as you said it's what she
did for women's sport
in general because
to restore you suzanne lenglen she was
born in 1899 is the grow up so of  grew
up in a bourgeois family she was
born in paris but quickly she left
for the north of france her father had her
but put her in tennis and in fact he
quickly discovered her predispositions
so she will grow up in the she will
grow  ndir she participates in her first
major tournaments
when she is only 14 15 years old
themselves champion champion of France in
mixed at 15 finally it is to say who has
already she is very precocious is in fact
after the war will happen here and
after the war comes what we called
the beautiful era
so it's a time here we want to
forget the first world war we
want to try to it's a kind of image
of france which is a little
idealized today  but it also represents for
the bourgeoisie, of which perhaps
a certain part is still part,
here it is, there are a lot of parties
in Paris, it's very crowded,
but despite everything, we are in a period
which, even if we idealize it today  Today
is all the same quite special and
especially for women because
women are still very much under the aegis
of their husbands very much under male domination
there is very little autonomy at
this time and that is why the
course at that time of schenge  n is
even more impressive all these
victories all and all these trips he
has made around the world are even
more beautiful since in fact she is
emancipating herself she is very avant-
garde in her way and many
to see her sport  and to lead her life, for
example, she has already revolutionized the
way she dresses
too, that is to say that she does not hesitate
to put on a low neckline, has shown her shoulders
because for her, quite simply,
it is much more effective for her.
also wears her big fur coats
even this headband that she has in her
hair at the time it is very new
so she too is a little symbol of
this help a little symbol of this of
this period suzanne lenglen and in
it's really that's why
we also called her the divine it's that
really there are thousands of people
who come to see her that is to say that you
see she's going to do she's going to go to
united states she will become the first
professional french player  sional that is
to say that well she will be paid
because when they win when she
is champion of france and
world champion she wins wimbledon she and
she publishes amateurs but she decides
to stop this amateur career  and to
become professional she will be
paid for a kind of tour through and
well the United States where she will face in
particular the champion of the United States
of the time and she will and she will at
that time fill a madison square
garden  because for having played it in an
exhibition match, it's nearly 13,000
Americans who will have at that
time it's to tell you a little about
the impact it has that it has and a little
bit  the icon whatever they represent
and then well also the fact that it
's men as well as her who come to
see her
it's very very important and also she
will play a preponderant role with
what we later called  the four
musketeers because she is going to
coach is going to coach  men she will
also give them lots of lots of
advice and above all suzanne lenglen will
write books writes books
on on on tennis and that is
important to say because in fact
it is something that is very
traditional especially in the sword fight
I don't know if you know gaël but there are a
lot of books that talk about
how this fight starts
fight with a sword two ep there are a
lot of treats like that about
chivalry and duels that existed but
she is going to do a kind of initiation that
looks a little bit like that or well
he is going to explain how to play tennis
in this way of also democratizing
this sport so here it is a course
quite quite enough  unique suzanne lenglen
and that I invite you to go and
find out
I'm shortening a little bit what I
'm telling you but in any case it's really
she's really very she's really
fascinating is it you you were
interested in suzanne  lenglen where do
we tend not necessarily when you're there
tennis player andy you know
suzanne lenglen you are interested in it listen
I simply immersed myself in knowing
enough stupidly roof so that we called
the court suzanne lenglen choice and therefore
inevitably when you  you're very young I
slept roland garros wants to know
why philippe chatrier why
suzanne lenglen and suddenly I was able to
dig a little bit into roland garros
necessarily talked to a lot of people
for quebec who was suzanne
lenglen what  she had been able to achieve and
low all that you have said a little and you
know there is really a sentence that
comes up often it is the first
player to play in a skirt
you see it's really it was
something these are there  in tennis was
really what it really was he
was the first person to play in a
skirt
so now it seems a little
weird in quotes but that's
really what made him
really score  hot let's say
it was here it was the first time that
a woman came in a skirt to play
tennis what her clients were and above all
you should know that the queen of england
was a fan of suzanne lenglen and that in
fact this  what happened is that one day
that lengagne is participating in wimbledon and
the organizers change their
tournament schedule they say you have to
play your singles and
doubles match in a row and except that she says I
am  injured I can't too much and
everything and I can't go and so
she refuses at that moment because in
fact for her it's unfair to see
like that to play when she is
injured and that in addition she  must in addition
she must chain her matches she
refuses to play in front of the
British public is in front of the Queen
of England and say to apologize afterwards
to the Queen with thanks to a friend
but to also tell you that she had
anyway  quite a strength of character
but after the obviously the British
public  annique but will be worth it
for a little while afterwards but here's a
lot of stories it's full
of stories then and she will
also stop her career after this
rather rather unfortunate episode so that's it
for suzanne lenglen game don't hesitate to
watch them don't hesitate to find
out about this lady who today we call
the divine for all that
she brought to tennis
much more than beyond
tennis and that too which is
very important  going back to
the time of suzanne lenglen also made me
want to go back a little bit
to the origins of roland garros and to the
somewhat surprising anecdotes and
this time it's you gaël it's you
who must  save
people places because I'm preparing a little quiz for you
I was preparing a very little quiz those
of true or false these five questions
I'm very fresh I hope you're
ready do we have a stinger in control
or  do we go straight
or do we or  can i go
but peaceful liked it very well blow i
take first question then it was
true or false i give you an affirmation
1983 roland garros the right answers
no i have to give you three
right answers out of five in  true I'm
nice to you was not going to resale place
it's because you did ok then first
question the construction of the
central court the first so which was created
in 1927 was chaotic and lasted 14 years
only really
when they  conquered wanted to
build the first stadium the first
central court of roland garros it was a bore it
lasted 14 years what a
problem and it's at roland garros
yes but not yet in languages it was n
t yet called roland garros at  that
moment but it was going to become
roland garros is it true
what is false it's his voice is
it true because it is false and it
starts this body in 1927  invites to 10.27
wayne august 27 and i would say yes because
moreover yes well it is false
absolutely not it is false in reality
it is even completely the reverse
since in fact the first central court
therefore after evolved a lot was created
in less than six months since in fact the
four  musketeers had just won and
well the davis cup in the united states a
few months ago they said
we absolutely have to be a place
to welcome the public and so in six
months they built the central court
with reinforced concrete they  are they are
heated they found an architect
they set up the project and in six months
saw saw the ground came out of the ground the
center court probably only small a
few small places that needed to be
improved there were a few small
stands which were temporary but
basically  they created a court capable of attracting a
lot of audiences for the
davis cup and the four musketeers
of course friends it's not tarpaulins
that you see because I couldn't
find a faithful image of  see just a
word first we'll we'll take this one that'll be
enough another question in
addition to the questions another statement
is it true because it's
false roland garros hosted
ice hockey matches
so frankly
chéreau finished  and I wanted fault in you
it's false there has never been a
roland garros match on clay
what hockey never at roland
garros is never an image of
renting the water they have  put they
put two ice rinks in place I know
I don't know it's up to you to find me
hockey the year he's smart he's smart
listen I won't say good well well listen
unfortunately it's true it's true he
there was even then there were even several
matches I had a first time of 1938
a france belgium and even there was a
world championship in 1951 where
canada moreover imposes itself and they
played matches of this cup  of the world
of this huge world championship at roland
garros
I have never heard of  and that if there
were matches there were
Moroccan women she has ears or 1938
and 1951 and we may have had more
recent ones there may be more recent ones
but in any case the first date back
quite a bit to this  period there ok you see
later i'll hit it frankly i give
you i don't give you presents because
they are they are difficult i
felt if i give you an easier one the
port remained not even born coisy lacoste
was a man was in  made a member
of the French tennis team
of course so it's true you have to
do it's true obviously obviously
what you had trained a member of the
famous four musketeers in the
20s so by the way who has  been
trained by suzanne
lenglen moreover to say it either
harvests rené lacoste
obviously you know
the anecdote of why did
crocodiles become the symbol then of the
brand
I have a story but maybe  be I
know her the weight of the months then in  big
the story is that he had just
before a game with his coach he
had bet that if he could win a game
he buys he would buy a
crocodile bag is in fact he said ok if I
win unfortunately he lost but
l  the story of the crocodile bag remained
mainly because in relation to his
character since the story says that
he never buys a match so suddenly
we kept the story of the crocodile
ok so here it was his nickname so
it  is what we called
it that's why we also called it so you
have a good first point
for you we go on to another question
and clay is a surface
of Italian origin which is true  or
is it wrong me i think
it's wrong it's wrong for you yeah
it's wrong ok well well that's a good
answer indeed it's wrong
clay in celebration would have two
origins  there are two theories on
the origin of clay
some would say that it would come
from tennis it is  that he in the ancestor
of tennis aces with in particular the
tuileries where there was already this
something which resembled this famous
raking ground where it is also said that his
two brothers who would have created in cannes at the end of
around 1870 the renshaw brothers who for
protecting their lawn would have put
earth on top and therefore would have
created clay at that time
so there are several there are several there
are several theories but it is the
two main ones that stand out but
indeed the two origins and two
theories  are very French so
absolutely and there you won his second
point is there at chrtr the fateful
and there it's true I am I am will be
and this is the last question before
Roland-Garros before the French internationals
there  had the
international france tennis championship which later
became the internationals and during this
international france
tennis championship there were only five
participants is it true or
is it  -which is wrong so
master in fact in fact there was that
but I don't know if there were shocks
with 5 it wasn't eight genres like the
masters it was then the rule
the rule it was  when big this
international french championship you
could be an international player who
could very well be american
you have to be licensed in france had been
done either dismissed a french club well
me I would say true because that I
finally knew I  I knew six in Le Havre
beat driving was there I'm lying
back with is hot it's true is
a good answer actually it's
serving cros was eight months it was 5
7 6 5
it was five years actually they did
were only 5 during the first
championship of during the first
international championship of France and
in addition to that it is a British
who won it at a certain age brics so
was dismissed from the French stadium at
the time and who wins the  first
international french championships and
i  there were only five placements it
's not him it's an
illustration image obviously but therefore put
quite a good answer on it
gaël very very very stylish that I was
very good you have three out of five I  you're
doing well in the chat you were
happy hockey by doc who dates 4 out of 5
too so you're doing well it was
hot I'm going to look for real I'm going to
look for complicated stuff really
hard really really very hard but you
see the last game
this story age I knew
ice hockey really no idea
frankly that's for sure but look
and see the stadium in 1927
no idea also really yeah you saw
but it's cool at least you learned
some stuff  exactly like that would give you a
little anecdote to shine in meals you
know when you have to say of course
I knew it that you necessarily know
in trivial pursuit also there are
always questions like that so it's
perfect what exactly
thanks to his  pursuit when you  go he will
perform 2 so thanks to that you
allow to win
two additional places also two
additional places for roland
garros
is what we put a thank you to mr cicadas
in the chat for where did we have
planned an order to speak because
you want it's winning at the eba thank you
war in the chat one the clothes we
left for mercy gaël the friends to
win the place of roland garros of
course offered by the bnp
paris friends  two places every time
we forgot to specify the friends it's two
places on the court philippe chatrier the
central because I know that in
which I had seen his two trays in
the friends on on the philippe-chatrier
on  the central court
so we of course thank the bnp paribas
for offering this to you so we left on
sea cicada and the winner enough
space also we will give the names of the
two winners very well we will we will
therefore make the draw at the same  time we
will enjoy it  to make the draw for
the bracket
precisely so we said it we will
give you after the results of the winners
for the places of roland garros afterwards
take advantage of it for my mother and we
also believe and we will also of course win
some keys for the game  tennis is a
sport around them exact
no we haven't forgotten all that friends
it's leaving and I think we're gone
I would like her to listen perfect for
the bracket so so I put a  number of
which there are eight participants I put a
number per participant you have to
choose me each time for each
meeting a number between 1 and 8
so what the first meeting I
would like to see you you would like to see who 4
and 16 -  4 and 7 4 and 7 4 and 7 so
for the bracket
we're going to look at that we're going to show you
the bracket quickly to see who's
going to compete I'll remind you for it's
so it will be up to lise alessandro
to bring so  the italian player so
who at 26 years old who comes to us from rome and who
i did not lose any set during his
qualification he will play against the
brazilian player against taste gargaud mort terra
exactly so on that 27 years old who
comes to us from who lives in sao paulo
today who also did not lose
any game during  its qualification so
two a good big to good big quarter-
final there waiting for us so you at 10
4 and 7 for this first give me the
next two for page 2 and 5 2 and 5
and so
what who so who practice
field hockey, moreover, he who will play
against the euro, there the little Franco-
French-English match which delights me and there it is
very good since it is Augustin Bodine
and therefore comes to us from Reims who will play
against the British for this quarter
finals so that gives us a tree an
interesting tree on the side of the scoreboard which is
going to be interesting so to lead them
to the grand final
we go to the other side of the scoreboard
gaël donges for I can finally change I
can come back to d  'other numbers I
can say 1,  5 at the show that I put
on number one so you already said
you already said about her ok I'm going to her
so I'm going to take then I'll take
and 8 1-8
and so it will be rodriguez
the  spanish gsm treats against the
belgian player so i hope i'm
not going to scratch his name kevin van aerschodt
van aerschodt i hope i'm not saying
getac young people and when i pass his name
so our belgian friends who will have
their representatives  for this quarter-
final and therefore the last two players
who are therefore number 3 manfred mann
ou secs precisely facing alexandre
lépine
so as we said they were
the winner of the
wearetennis qualification and well it's a pleasure
we  drew lots it's a
I feel like I was a little bit into
something a little solemn had to draw
lots
bassékou left a beautiful painting is all
me I'm glad we didn't draw
the  two French people are against
each other
at least that's cool they are in
two p  table parts maybe we
'll have a Franco-French final who
knows and that's what we're doing with it clearly
absolutely
and that's very cool and that's happening
in a month that's it in a  month at
roland garros absolutely and besides
so manfred to us is that alexandre is going to
face alexandre let's start a match he has been
playing tennis for 17 years now
he has been a coach for three years and
his dream as he said totally
the video is  is that he wanted to become
a professional tennis player and there in
real life he goes to roland in real life it's cool
you see it's nice when big
fans like that tennis that happens to
roland suddenly not necessarily through the
court  but precisely by the
video game it's really very cool
and besides we are going to take advantage of it at the same
time friends to win the
keys
so we stop the thanks gaël we mark
hergé in the chat to win
keys  world tour tennis tennis
world tennis friends everything to do
by  shot from now crg and a drop of the
keys friends from europe of the keys to the
game
don't forget that friends all the names
of the winners that we will be able to list later
will have five minutes
to show up with everyone  mods who
will simply come and
contact you if there is no
demonstration we will have to
draw lots of course the friends so exactly
there is no such thing just answer
the mods to manifest you just to
confirm your  your look in
fact your presence your presence quite
simply
is what the management suddenly
has time for me I would like to have
one or two fans who answered on
the thing and qourna a person
it is the one  perceived to become a fan with and
where perfect baptiste to close
the show would be top or a point to
change with him
exactly body and will be able to tell us
which year roland garros was won
by the only Frenchman just to see if
eyelash to eyelash to eyelash  followed the  e game and see
if there are any ice hockey matches
here you see you see you there
what am I going to say oh yes also two
sisters with
and gabriel talked about the rankings and
said that it was zero  and minus two
is a lot for their age and heroes and
-2 I don't realize about the
rankings on his wishes ranking
l'aja des leases ranking 7th in the
ranking
you see that age there it's already good
rankings
I myself  don't remember very well anymore because
in fact they changed a little bit
but it's because in fact it stops
at -15 now and I don't remember
you very well anymore I know the first 100
French people so that's it
the first 100 French are still approaching very quickly
so not given up in the ranking so no
I think it sent heavy
the local siga belhouane was already serving
heavy too cool too interesting in real life
I like to see it is in a
few years  what is justin
roland garros juniors that would be cool
when to start to start it's
always incredible your first role in
juniors it's exceptional it's
incredible to touch your finger already a
first and a first stage what you know
like crazy me I was like crazy
not to go  you win it and you roland
garros juniors noah but the first
time i participated task is not
thin ip with two years advanced
i had game brian dabul the world number 1
at the time i wanted it was
horrible without that I had lost on the
field of the office of 17 and I
remember everything I had lost 3 7
6 also because you are well hung
anyway and I was like crazy
frankly I put like crazy  it
had to be so I put choice prices that
we can we can say so we were going to
win
we have the winners or
can you send them
to us in case the winners are there so the
winners for the places  from roland
garros you see they are right here
in amorphous and us 95 and foot  de biche
so play well admit so you will go to
roland you will just have to show up
so for I think that's what
it's done sk a modo millan you can
tell me that they showed up or in
the recognized region say  what you are
calais with with the winners
of the roland garros passes
and that way we are sure that segou
2 but there
hermes therefore has no problem no
problem and I have a question for that
was confirmed at the dock that  has been
confirmed that i have me i write saxe in the
chat i know you are there are we
talking about morpheus perfect cover or not
because it would still be super
funny anyway if it was really
him  if you can confirm his crisis and
put the year says I'm just waiting for products
ok ok no problem but that doesn't
keep you informed melanocytes no
news unfortunately we're going to have to go to the
roads where we incredible incredible 10
baptists who with us so  which is
athletic because they in preparation for a
iron man is therefore apparently the
little questions to ask us too
hi baptiste hi you're fine you're fine
you
good evening it's ok you have us that's ok
from argenteuil ac and next to paris next
to roland choice goes very far 9.2  I take
advantage of it
exactly yeah so suddenly I had
a little question of faith how do you
feel close to roland with the
public empty premises how do you feel
not close to roland listen better than
last year much better than
l  '
last year last year it was really very
chaotic you see I didn't necessarily know it's
starting to be
better in my head so I'm going to have
less rip this year because I have
n't played but besides I'm going  say
is officially I can say that my
recovery and in rome twice and in
rome
you go official I train well I
feel good I have I have done a lot of
vacuum also you see a little with 7 with
this period of  covile i think
i need to do a lot of  empty 2
me we're going to say get back to work
in a slightly different way so you
see I'm going to have three big
roland garros tournaments hoping to make as
many roland garros matches as possible this
year again madrid
no there's rome I was playing rome
lyon  is a week ago a
week before before roland garros where there
are two tournaments there is either a tournament
in italy or a tournament in serbia and i
think i will play one of the two
so i play a full week and
well ready roland garros two matches of
my passion that's that that's that a maximum
of matches and a lot of desire it's been a
long time since I played a lot
in life so and the public everything will be
more public this year so  that
's cool you see 5400 me that's it's
coming it's brewing and it's huge it's
exactly exactly it's been a long time
since you generally I did
n't do it being public and all that so it's
true that  it's still nice
that finally there is what don  c so so
it's cool suddenly you did an
ironman
you can tell us a little less 70
3 me I call the course of the mazots
because in fact it's 3 km 9 of
swimming 180 of cycling and a  marathon and
even I know that I would be unable
to do so already me it's mine
it's a 9 kilometer of swimming 90 of
cycling and rebellious so already if I tell myself
that I manage to finish it I would already be
extremely  happy have done what they
are doing we are preparing we are cycling
running my swimming for
the moment it is at a standstill because
all the empty premises everything is closed
and I am preparing as best we can you
go do it or we do what we can
i'm going to do it in vichy that's what
a little chick did i'm going with
friends to look at the big dedication to
you you've been doing this for a long time
it's your first you did another
sport before or so I
obviously play tennis but really
the ironman
it was decided on a c  oops I was
watching a video of the cost of a summary
I stayed the nice ironman and
I said to myself well come on go really
on a whim I didn't have a bike
I had nothing like equipment and  I'm
intrigued but buy everything in a
hurry
so here it is really on a
whim and really I'm happy to be able
to do it and I hope to do the best
possible our determination
exactly the determination is
important big mental I like small
last trivial question just question
about video games you the new
season of warzone what do you think
the news set me at 20 days
applies to me I like me I
like and I like I
I really like the new map I really find it I
find it really cool I'm a little
lost I haven't been hiding you there for a
few days with the new
classes because you see now they
've been very calm the last one who put them back there
aren't too many  metas so village
I can't  too much to know you see I'm
not hiding the beer from you yesterday
I was still seeing what I'm playing
at max a case what is playing at maxime 63
July 10 India
yeah the lc 10 it's there but you
can't arrive  know suddenly these
felt thresholds or more exactly what
exactly
you like the new bank I
'm not too lost apart from three
sites at the level of the repentances a lot
of glances from the couffo well how much take
new bearings but frankly that's fine
I manage  not too bad I have we
still manage to keep the marks for
years and above all I swear it has undergone
some a little different also is a
plus which
I still expected them to
patch a little as pink and even the
new ones  operators
I want a dialogue did nothing
they just removed a piece of sleeve
at the level of the means done we put in
millimeters of water woolly skin length
it's nice with great pleasure
and then there you go thank you very much
and well that's wonderful  incredible
batista he's warming up and the
Vaudois title I only do half of an
environment
it's okay it's still it's not bad
it's exceptional I find it
exceptional so stay an hour there
the management we have the name  winners for
the
man thor 2 tennis keys they are ok they
were all contacted apparently on the
stadium so apparently ok well fine
perfect apparently everyone will be
contacted afterwards everyone for
the keys i have the impression that  it was
frankly shores to finish
frankly to redo pass quickly all the
same it went quickly except on the on
the quiz but otherwise it was it was
nickel it's too good but to redo or
not happens but to redo  direct
obviously to the way of doing it again but
that's why I say to do it again but
obviously to do since we meet again
on May 29 both of us already
no next May 29 the match will be a
roland garros with the with
finalists with the two finalists so
is  what we will do again a show
together to precisely watch
the grand finale of this roland garros is
here is by bnp paribas and so we hope
you hope that many of you will
also be watching us because it was
a great show it  is an opportunity to
talk about 10 sports but also to talk about
sports I'm with low with luan and
gabriel thank you very much for coming thank you
very much also to yannick and a
celeste not for coming because it
was very interesting exchanges
really super interesting and I
think the resignation is going to be super
interesting I will be a little more
stressed as it will be the day before
Roland Garros
yes you put in everything is less
obvious in the mode where I will be I will be a
little more stressed but I am  I
will give you real quizzes but I
think I will ask not to play the
next day as soon as I have I will still have
it will be a relaxing moment it's always
a relaxing moment but in any case
as you say I would like to really  like to
thank gabriel and loane because it
was really wanted to become yannick
it was really super interesting so
a big thank you to yannick agnel the
mcs team frankly it was cool
a big thank you to bnp paribas because
he over time we're really offered  a lot
of a lot of space and each time they
have ideas
you see I like they have ideas
of helping to broadcast and inevitably
it's a super important sponsor is
emblematic of roland garros so
I have each  times I never stop
thanking them so really a big thank you to
bnp paribas a big thank you to roland
garros also because here is roland
garros they are behind all this so a
big thank you a big thank you to roland
garros is here is by bnp paribas
because  that's another firm too and
frankly it's super cool what they
do for tennis because it helps
even if it's sport it also helps
tennis it helps our environment to
develop so I would like  really
re  thank you all that it's cool it's a
great discussion with them we
really feel that they tried to think about
the thing the show that it would be good
to have ideas
to make the gamers milk and then we
see there  at least they got busy
they talked with the winged everyone and
it was really great I really liked
I want to say a big thank you to May to
Aymeric in particular to the
French federation who is who is
always  with us and bricks he's there he
's a real fan you can tell he's
a real fan and all it was his baby
frankly it was cool at who
were really excited and hope
my head active aymeric because i
thought  writing we really liked it
and let's see it's even lasting because
my friend says two hours we're a little
longer so really a big thank you to you
there especially for contacting us
for being able to set up this experience
and to finish a big  thanks to team
bold because every time guys  at
real tomtom nikon or vincent
everyone at team paul really makes me love you
and frankly a big
thank you to you and you I don't say thank you
because I thank rives ok I'll
tell you thank you here's what I'll tell you about
crash was  only what really a
rolling draw to roland I can't wait to see your
draw I hope it's going to go well
for you really there will be
the opportunity to talk about it again on the 29th the day before
and when you're like that in  2d mode
correct or you don't want to go there
hey really have my biggest thank you
- friends it's you on the chat you
were really numerous it's really
nice it's warm to the heart thank you
for being at  each time present friends
present appointment thank you very much to
all really it was a show a
kiff
of course we thanked a lot of
people but this show is for
you you make us who does it when
you are there many like that  is a
real real kif so much of the offer
on you  to the neck thank you thank you to you the
cat thank you for all and never forget
that tennis is only love
sport is only love sport
is only love we are all  a
big family we hope everything
is going well and I want to
send loft everywhere friends thank you
patrick sebastien it's god of love
if we want because if you see us
on May 29th  so on your game channel we're going
to enjoy it again it was too good to
manage everyone have a good
evening
good evening everyone thank you
laughter the chaos
[Music]